what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the sit down welcome to the show thanks
for having me thanks for having me I'm
curious I don't know what the what's
going to be asked so you haven't seen
too much in my show have you nah you
know what it is I like to not behave
like I'm media trains and all of that
and if I look into the show or start
looking into what to expect and how to
reply so I like it to just be natural
organic what if I come at you with some
crazy questions I won't answer them you
won't answer if they're crazy I try to
answer everything but if it's mad then
I'll just tell you you're moving mad
yeah I saw that on the ZZ interview she
asked you something about
like it was something sexual and you're
like nah I'm not answering that
a common boy it wasn't me as easy yeah
yeah
so um for the people in America that
might not know you're the most popular
engineer here you have
a popular YouTube channel which features
interviews and behind the scenes footage
with some of the biggest names in UK
drill
and your channel has become a go-to
destination for the genre as well as up
and coming artists looking to make a
name for themselves is there anything I
missed
I don't yeah I don't know it's mad I
don't like to say yeah I'm that guy on
this guy or whatever but it's nasty here
sometimes you know so how did you get
started and music production and
you know for me it was like I I always
like
I used to watch a lot of like movies in
terms of music like eight mile
get rich and I'll try and those two
films or two films that I looked at and
I was like
there's a lot of other people other than
the rappers
and they don't get no light whatsoever
like if you look at that then Get Rich
or Die Tryin from I think the engineers
highlighted he just gets capped just on
a random to send a message to someone
else and it's like that it's so deep he
got capped yeah whatever however
he died yeah no he got shot like but for
me it was like um obviously an eight
mile as well there's not really too much
on the
production on the
General executive roles it's just like
yeah I'm a rapper and I'm the star of
the show which is cool and then for me
it's like I felt like I can make
something of not being a rapper but I
can also live in a certain way that I
wrap a word in terms of Lifestyle see
what I'm saying so you don't have to be
that guy in front of the camera wrapping
your heart out you can be behind the
scenes of putting strings and still do
what they can potentially do lifestyle
wise and look after your people and your
family and all of that so I don't know
that's when I decided to try and make
this something that I can take for and
brand it yeah because I've actually
never heard of another engineer actually
I don't
I'm beginning because I was like I don't
wanna yeah um did you ever try rapping
did you ever do that too yeah yeah yeah
I did that I'll go all mixed it are you
a whole next day yeah it's crazy I won't
tell you about to find out nothing
we can't can we react to it I won't tell
you it's fine but if you find it do what
you want because I can't take it out so
yeah I can't remember to log in so yeah
how did you initially approach working
with different artists
when I became an engineer son I knew I
needed to do because for me there's a
lot of people and take nothing away from
those kind of people but from where I'm
sitting I was like I always wanted to be
someone where
I built my own name so it's not like my
name's attached to someone else or
something else or a company or a label
like yeah this person's that from this
label because of this label or because
of this radio show or because of this
artistic I'm saying so I knew I needed
to just work with everyone and prove
that I'm the best of what I do and get
the best out of the artist that I'm
working with which is what I try and do
I'd say I've got at least a 8 out of 10.
over there in terms of yeah I get it
done more time but yeah so
I was already doing nothing so when I
when it started becoming a thing that
everyone started to see that was already
happening behind the scenes for that
seven eight years when did you start
plugged in two three years ago and how
did you come up with the idea
during the pandemic lockdown and no one
was allowed out I was like what
I'm gonna be outside
but everyone's inside so the way my head
works is just like I just look for
opportunities everyone's inside what are
their brain looking for stuff to do
stream
whatever I spent a lot of time on
Warzone when it first came out like
banging out with my presence and then I
was like you know what
every time my music video came out
I felt like everyone that I know was
like yo have you seen this have you seen
this because no one's doing nothing
everyone was not allowed to leave the
house I was like you know what I need to
make something that they can see
sounds like I suppose a couple people
whatever that's a lot down and I was
like whoa technically you're not to mix
and blend with six people at the moment
but they say don't go out so technically
there was a loophole in the work because
I went on a golf website and I found a
little loophole and the police bangling
my door every single day and I hit them
in the same loophole here it is on the
website guys take it off the website
what was that was the loop hole you're
allowed to be with someone in the same
facility the six of you now you're not
allowed it was mad because you're not
allowed to be out with other people but
in a building you was allowed to have
six people
there was something along those lines so
obviously as soon as we got in the
building we was calm
and it was one time now yeah it wasn't
common then yeah we had a rapper that
jumped out the window it was not a high
window he jumped out the window yeah the
police came yeah yeah but he talked
about the window for a difference you
were doing if you're inside
because I have really bad luck with
landlords and my landlords just they
just hate that it's
I don't know it was just like you know
what why is he here we want our money
but we don't need to be in the buildings
and I'm saying you wouldn't know I'm in
the buildings and if you was here
yourself so you're not supposed to be
here evil so realistically I mean so the
yeah they were just like yeah they just
kept calling the police online every
chance they got it got to the point
where they would just yeah did you film
it
um no I've never really been like that
in the Vlog you know what I wasn't I
wasn't really vlogging them time but I
started vlogging like kind of after that
oh okay that's some weird stuff was just
happening like people love conflict and
videos yeah it was like the police
coming I don't know yeah
you know it is I got enough drama from
the police already in terms of like the
music art and they're always trying to
take videos down in restrict languages
and all of this stuff so I'm just like
oh maybe not antagonize them they'd be
leaving me alone recently so let me just
they take the videos down oh yeah
they're brutal how they just contact
YouTube and say you know we don't want
this one out this one here implements a
crime
they don't really have to say much more
YouTube the UK YouTube just rolled over
some little puppies they're just like
okay we'll do whatever you say but the
U.S YouTuber like afraid of experience
TK the race still up that's why the race
I'm really bad with music is that whose
song is that
um I used to do rap reactions when I
first started my channel
like reaction videos yeah yeah it was
like whitest girl on earth reacts to
like push I steers all over here that's
how I started on YouTube and there was
one
um that was a guy literally rapping
about him he like broke out of jail and
then made a YouTube video about a murder
and I think it was called the race if I
take it so how is that allowed but yours
is that's in the U.S right yeah in the
U.S that's why I say they fight freedom
of speech or whatever maybe they just
don't care and the police over here
they're like yo he mentioned this even
though it's blood they'll be like we we
think it's this so delete the video
and then YouTube will be like okay if
you want us to delete it but aren't you
innocent until proven guilty not here
not when it comes to music wow wow like
the police will just be like yeah this
one here we feel like he might have said
this because more time is blood and if
it isn't blood then it's like yeah he
said this so get him to delete it but
it's not when they get him to the Leah
they're not thinking about the
production the cost the value what art
is put forward into that they're just
thinking oh well we don't want it we
don't want to hear it so don't listen to
them bro no because I can imagine for me
anyway if like someone wanted me to take
down a whole show like that would that
would be a lot yes you pay everybody you
put all this work into creating
something exactly and the police can
just tell you to take it down when they
feel like it no and then and looking at
it from where they're coming from I mean
sometimes some of the stuff said goes a
little bit far so it's not you know what
this one's a bit Ott the leaders and the
slack
YouTube would just say yeah we don't
have a say as a platform you know what
I'm saying YouTube will just say yeah
actually we do we can say no and then
YouTube just delete the whole Channel
anyway so the YouTuber like even we
delete that video or you can play big
and bad and we'll just delete your whole
so it's like Okay cool so we just
get pulled into a corner to delete our
video but sometimes it makes sense and
sometimes it's it don't like a lot of
the time it don't see the way I'm
thinking I'm like thinking of ways
around it I'm like couldn't you just put
it on a random Channel and they couldn't
prove it to you
that's what I would that's what I would
do yeah but they don't get the same
traction yeah but then same time if it
starts to get engagement then they'll
take it down yeah
but what what they haven't been able to
do effectively which will all bless that
for this moment in time is affect
Spotify and apple music because YouTube
didn't say yeah delete and they just go
with it when they message Spotify on
Apple music they don't really get the
same the police don't get the same love
back from them they're just like it's
music freedom of speech leave us alone
we're not involved and they just let us
stay up nine times out of them has rare
occasions I've heard a song from Spotify
has come down
when did you first realize that plugged
in was going to be big
was there like a moment where you're
like I have something here
that's a little question it's not no you
don't you don't realize it until you're
like 13 million views you didn't think
one video you have one video that had 13
million views on it I don't think I've
got 150 but at the same time it's
wow 50 million that's that's bad yeah
but you don't I can't explain it you
don't think about it and sit there and
be like I made it now I'm saying it's
like once you get there the next
challenge is how do we get more videos
there
and then once we get there is how do we
get taken to the next level one how do
we sit in the same room as the Beyonce's
and Jay-Z's now the game saying so it's
not like
you know that I don't know from the
start you kind of it doesn't really
matter it didn't matter about the views
on plugged in for me it was always about
like mentally I knew I had something
because me as a businessman I just I'm
determined to get it done and it's not
over until I win see what I'm saying so
it's like for me it's like I knew I had
something I knew something was going to
happen but there's no point where I've
looked here I mean like yeah I got it
now have you always had that mentality
yeah like ever since you were a kid yeah
your friends know as a kid that you're
going to be something big I consider
myself you know a popular loner yeah
yeah no friends
but more like a queen season like I'm
not around people a lot see I'm saying
like more time if you see me I'm out and
about there's a big chance that I'm
alone if that makes sense so I'm like
you know consider myself
but the mentality you've had since you
were a kid has been yeah and it's not
over till I win I remember on that it's
crazy but it all started with games
a lot in games yeah it'll start with
games like I remember playing a game my
mom bought around my friend and it was
really good at this game I think it was
Mortal Kombat
and he whooped my horse
but I'm not good with with taking L's
like that and he lead on the whole
showboat in and all of that and I said
all right cool and then he went upstairs
and he was just like whatever they was
just chilling whatever
I was downstairs banging out this game
by about four hours later I'll come up
and I'll come out upstairs like yo it's
6 p.m come back downstairs I've been
playing this game come back downstairs
oh he's awesome that's when I realized
it's not over until I win I don't know
how old are you I think I was like 11 at
the time I was like yes
and when did you start um learning
engineering 13 14. holder
you know
you know I just had a birthday I started
to feel old man 16th right yeah yeah so
yeah you've done the research I thought
yeah
I'm not spring chicken
a lot of things need to go the way that
they should go there's no more I'm not
much more what if I guess that's the one
yeah
uh we've been doing it for a while
that's really the reason I asked yeah
I've been doing it for a long time a lot
longer than everyone thinks and how long
was your rap career
I don't know about two for years but two
three years I'm not one music video
them times music videos weren't really a
thing like that but sometimes it was
China you were you just more passionate
about the engineering than rapping
I was just passionate about music I know
when I figured out like hold on no one's
winning per se as a executive producer
as an engineer as a producer you saw gas
in the market then I saw a gap and I was
like
is there a gap for a reason why is no
one trying to push that like you got
your beat composers your doctor dreams
and all that are just kidding it but
then also Dr Jason producers also yeah
but at the same time it's like there's
very few and no one in the UK was doing
it and I was like yeah let me hear and
see what happens
yeah because you're
you're so you kind of combined like rap
reaction videos yeah yeah that's what it
sort of reminded me of because I used to
do the rap reaction so it's kind of like
a combo but it's like in person and no
one I haven't really seen that before
that was a lot down thing because
obviously I stumbled across and I gotta
give credit to people that guns and
wrens produced by walks like those
people like really
had the industry there was a moment
where every video I got done the
reaction was so important and I looked
here and I was like it's funny to see
how people respond to music and I was
like yeah let me mix the best of both
get a hold of the spread 50 50 let's go
without the talking because that's the
one part that they hate on top of Music
the talking yeah what do you mean for
reactors it's cool but like say for
example DJs and people that are in the
music at the time they hate when people
keep talking over the intros and keep
talking in the middle of the songs and
yeah I've seen the comments they hate
that so I said no talking no audio just
visual
that's cool yeah that's Theodore's yell
at me if I paused it too many times
exactly but you get hit with do you
monetize your videos because I would
always get hit with copyright
yeah but I own the content so yeah
I didn't think about that
it will probably be someone from my
label here and you have a copyright and
then you'd ask me to write this day and
another Blanche oh yeah because I
stopped doing those reactions because it
would just be everything they were
brutal yeah yeah because when you do big
songs obviously the labels and all that
money everyone's in Dual Star would
admit it but everyone's indoors
some people some people have criticized
UK drill music for promoting negative
stereotypes and glamorizing violence how
do you respond to these criticisms
sometimes not everything is Glitz and
glamor with the drill music
but for me I just look at like
I'm actually a product of drill music
like without the Dual scene I wouldn't
be where I am now
but I haven't had to indulge or live a
lifestyle that that that you
stereotype with that so for me it's like
everyone can say there's some wartness
and taught this but at the end of the
days what do you do with your own life
like what have you managed to build like
I've seen people that have managed to
buy their mum properties cars look after
their family put their friends in
business roles now chicken I'm saying so
even though it comes with negatives
everything has negatives but I tried to
try and look at the positives and what
you can get out of it in a positive way
to move to the rest of the scene forward
and right now
it's a it's very dominant in the
industry a lot of people are doing draw
a lot of people are chatting a lot of
people are making money making six
figures some seven figure doors off of
music and it's drill music so to look
here and just say it's all negative it's
a lot of entertainment but in general
contrast controversy is selling and
that's what drum music really
predominantly is that controversy you
know what I'm saying but I just view it
all As
entertainment within the lines if that
makes sense there's Parts where this
goes a bit too much and they're just
like yeah okay cool you're doing too
much kid but it did it it's not just
your music it's everything well that was
like something I noticed when I was
reacting to rap music in general it
seems like there's like incentive
um especially in the US it seems like
you guys don't get away with it as much
here but to like almost commit crimes
and like rap about them
in and maybe maybe not crimes here but
just like
almost like there's incentive to put
drama in the music
I think like I don't know why and I feel
like you know I feel like it's
it's weird because
how old was Tupac when he allegedly died
you know I don't know I feel like he's
in his 20s he was young yeah but this is
the thing that
they were rapping about who shot your
rare and they were in they were putting
their dramas in music from way back then
but not many people were complaining
about it 50 Cent I got shot nine times
like I got hit like he got hit but he
ain't breathing like that's been in
music for a long long time it has and at
Young ages I feel like 50 Cent was also
in his 20s maybe late 30s going into
that type of that time in his career but
now it's like because
yeah maybe four years younger five years
younger it's a mad thing though
you see what I'm saying it's a math one
it's mad like it's just everyone's like
Whoa We have to end this but it's like
I'm I'm saying it's always been that way
it's yeah for me I don't remember I
don't remember listening to 50 Cent and
him rapping positivity but that's my
favorite that's like my favorite
individual I want to say RS but as an
individual businessman he's the goat I'm
saying so but I don't remember him
having no positive see what I'm saying I
feel same way about Tupac I think people
have like a halo over here I don't I
don't really know that type but I'm more
of a country yeah I do freestyle a
little bits whatever you know
but I grew up like listening to country
but it was when they would talk about if
Tupac like helped more than hurt
um but I would read his lyrics and they
were crazy but I don't I don't know his
yeah it's it's not nice it's like
I just think music in general like even
if you take it out outside of urban and
you know hip-hop rap and you bring it
him into a heavy metal and
they raped they they sing some crazy
lyrics nah not country I grew up on
Country country's not like that okay
yeah country is like
I lost my girl
it's always love songs country yeah I
mean I don't I don't really listen to it
yeah I mean yeah
yeah there is positive in everything
that's like gospels obviously it's going
to be great in it but
what's entertaining what's what were
people talking about I don't feel like
country songs get spoken of yeah well I
think it's entertainment in general
promotes drama in a way because what's
more entertaining everyone getting along
exactly or you know everyone wants to
see people that the two biggest boxes
fighting each other is drama you know
what I'm saying no one wants to see the
two biggest people creating Club case
yeah but I think I think the criticism
generally is like are we playing into it
and that's the world we live in we look
we log on to the news because of the
drama like no one log on to them used to
see you you know I don't know
something everyone talks when there's a
mad thing happened
turkey everyone's now oh my God oh my
God but when they were doing good stuff
and so they're not everyone's girlfriend
it wasn't the topic of the conversation
you know I'm saying now like oh wow
something crazy has happened and people
are being hurt and it's very unfortunate
everyone's onto the topic now like
is because of the situation
if they were doing loads of great stuff
which they have been doing I don't I
didn't see the same response right so it
doesn't get as many eyeballs exactly but
they've done so much positive for for so
many different people from different
countries even down to Clover and stuff
I don't see like everyone saying you
know what turkey is doing great guys
thank you we don't put that out there as
much it's when something drastic happens
uh what's your favorite song You've
mixed
I don't answer that
it's the same as what yeah what's your
favorite then I just don't like in
theory like everyone's gonna want it to
be theirs and I work with too many
people and I've got too many good
relationships to someone to be upset
about something else I don't what's your
least favorite oh wow definitely
what's your least favorite interview
um
I've only done like five that's like
that's why I'm like maybe some ones when
I didn't oh I got one for you I'll tell
you I'll tell you I interviewed this
girl and she was telling me how she
deserved a 200k engagement ring it was
very entertaining but like talking to
that level of delusion
um
yeah yeah she was telling me how she
that was what she wanted like a 200 000
engagement ring what's she in a
relationship no
I understand this delusion you
understand it why why no no I understand
like obviously you can't be in a
relationship and say those things right
I'm saying like she's basically trying
to say broke people stay away from me I
want a millionaire that's going to
really look after me yeah which is fine
if you're really hot
yeah like she's like she's like 33 she'd
never had a boyfriend so it's like
it's like if you're if you were that
yeah God bless her yeah like she was
talking to me after she wanted a 200 see
I could answer the question I could tell
you you kind of swept it because
obviously if you know you know but you
didn't say who because it's I forgot her
name honestly but it's probably better
you didn't say who but for me Taylor oh
wow
Taylor She's On You
um yeah
that's true yeah I can't do that yeah
yeah fair enough not everyone has
[Laughter]
real like I just feel like I'll tell you
yeah
yeah yes
Taylor's gonna pop off your Dimensions
he
actually I already reacted to it
I welcome her back though I
crazy to say two hundred thousand
dollars on an engagement are you gonna
spend two hundred thousand dollars on an
engagement engagement ring
are you gonna spend that
I mean it depends on oh you might no
should I give her your number
but it depends on like the situation now
to be honest if you're like
a billionaire
you might because people spend that on
their own jewelry qualifies for a
billionaire I don't know that's not
really my department I'm not there so I
mean you're a guy you could guys with
the most options who do they date
typically uh I don't speak for guys like
I'm My Own guy if that makes sense like
I like me I'm not quite a lot or you
know what I'm saying you don't think
there's like General truths though about
men in general
so like I could say women in general
like successful men in general
if I can't say that because a guy will
go for a broke girl like with all these
heart happy as long as she can like do
other things that make him happy yeah
but yeah men don't want a broke girl but
men
nah because I've met guys that are like
300 pound women that they're into yeah
but I know I've met guys that he
actually said to me he said to me bro do
you know what you need I need a five out
of ten no stress no headache you can
crack on with your business you'll
support you and everything's easy you
should look after the kids should be
she'll play her role and you need that
backbone structure and for a minute he
was getting somewhere I was like five
out of ten I hear you know because the
stresses have been real I don't know
it's like no I can't do that but that's
just me see what I'm saying but I said I
can't do that but I don't know I might
meet someone that's like she takes every
other box
um so I'm saying like in general man you
don't think men like young attractive
women okay cool but if he's 290 Pounds
they might be a match made in heaven
they might be able to get a son adult to
go off and work work on each other and
be each other's motivation to me for it
and win so most men 300 pounds am I most
women-free my point is I think these
explain General truths about men and
women right like men and women we don't
look for the same things
yeah I feel like women are just yeah
obviously you're not you look I'm more
like
let me not
going
yeah but
um just a bit more like
yeah I feel like you like kind of
you're meant to be looked after that
sounds a bit more and then you get your
standout I'm independent yeah there's
two sets of Europe there's the
Independent Women and they're meant to
be looked after women no not per se like
they they're meant to but I feel like
they kind of fall into like when you're
looking at girls it's like some of them
won't want to be a little tough though
some of them want to go out some of them
want you to stay home and look after the
kids you know what I'm saying and
they're like I'm independent and I'm
powerful and I'm a CEO of my you think
most women want to date men that make
less than them
I think women care a lot about that
but I'm not sure why
I get wired by the same time I'm not
sure why right but my whole point is
there's General truths about men and
women yeah 100 I do feel like you're
there with the with the women thing but
I can't that with the men I don't know I
don't really relate to half the minutes
you don't think okay oh come on you
don't think men like girls that look
good oh yes actually but that's
naturally
right but that's my whole point is if
she wants the richest men don't they
tend to go for beautiful models
Leonardo DiCaprio who does he usually
date I'm so bad I do I'll call you
belong to that but um
I hear you I hear what you're saying
yeah naturally yeah if you're in a
limelight you want someone that makes
sense for you to be in the land not with
me yeah it's like eye candy on the
shoulder and all of that trophies Meats
trophies and yeah he how is dating
changed for you from before you were
famous to being famous I'm not really
being single for Monday so I haven't
really done a lot of dates other than
the internet once okay so you've had a
girlfriend from before you were
her wife
well in a nutshell when I was single I
wasn't single for long if ever since I
was only single for that six months
several months okay and then I was into
a new relationship
yeah were the DMS crazy
yeah yeah I'm not gonna Capstone
some blue tickson yeah it's a match
though some medium followers yeah
because it's interesting because
guy's perspective from like before they
were famous and successful that to after
just the difference in like the women
that will like message them yeah I think
you know it's mud yeah I don't yeah it's
mad still yeah when you get money and
everything changes they they run off to
you like but at the same time it's not I
don't I don't personally go like if he
wasn't attractive before like
I don't know it just makes me feel like
you just attracted to the money or
okay it could look like Shrek and they'd
still run off to him like that
yeah I don't know
but that's the in the world of fun
that's fine yeah but not for like the
long term no no no I can't be realized I
don't know
that I don't know I'd be scared you're
trying to kill me in my sleep
after we get married and you just want
to take off because really you're here
for that then we've strugged out yeah no
that's scary I can't do that as a
successful guy's marriage
naturally on that
it's something I'm very open to you I'm
not against that at all
um but I am
very much against
having to do more than once I only want
to do it one time same with having my
first kid I only want to have one
baby mother and then that's me one baby
mother or wife
and one wife I don't want to have to do
what I'm saying so that they're gonna be
the same I'm not
trying to compromise on that no it's
just I feel like if I was a successful
guy it's like you kind of have more to
lose by getting married so I'm just
curious if you're cautious at all yeah
it's deep still about 50 is Dreadful but
I mean it can actually be like up to 70
here yeah no no it's 9 o'clock
[Laughter]
but obviously apparently prenups don't
work over here
I mean they can always be because it
sounds like a broad wedding one strip
yeah they can be thrown out because like
there's lawyers that are paid to figure
out how to throw them out
so like if you say you were gonna get
married in six months right and you gave
her the prenup three months before they
could say she was under duress
because you did it too close to the
wedding yeah stay stay woke
stay awake stage as well
are there like
are there because you don't have a ton
of you know you've only had I didn't see
any girls in your videos really not much
you don't
because I was gonna ask if there's like
like the the rap industry girls or
there's like have a certain reputation I
was just wondering if it's the same here
but you don't even have them in your
videos
not already here I mean I'm focusing on
like I've got a women's special for
women's Independence Day coming which is
just straightly women okay so I'm very
much focusing on making a campaign just
to support women on that one to make
sure that that goes off I just haven't
had a woman on the platform on her own
yet so I thought you know what let me
just get them all together and create
something that that no one's done before
I'm always trying to see little ways to
do things like yeah I freestyle a little
bit you know I'll get you in there
you're 16 boss
yeah
it's whatever though I don't want to
brag to you I don't want to like you go
yeah
brag to you that I don't want to show
off so just you know okay yeah don't
worry
I'm sorry
how were your dates with
um
Cheyenne and Amelia
what was that how did that happen
it's honestly a lot
um
about an app and someone said yeah you
should go on a date with this person and
they they kind of put it in play and I
was like ah caught that did they want to
do it they said yeah I said all right
let's do it I know from there I mean
Amelia's
Emilio and um Cheyenne was um
she was cool she was good man it was
just
that whole like Empire woman to just
be wild stating I was just like all
right cool man that's good for you and
they're allowed to be wild don't get me
wrong but just the starts behind this
you're so funny like all the cool story
well you don't think women should be
wild they're not to do whatever they
want oh that's what you think they
should do
I don't have a thought on what I think
women should do because I'm not a woman
and I don't live their daily life but as
a man I'm like there's certain things
that I prefer my woman to do and prefer
my woman not to do and then I lay them
out on the table at the start of any
kind of serious situationship friendship
relationship even if we're just doing
the friends with benefits thing I'll let
you know y'all if you want to attach my
name to yours and I'm going to touch it
yours to mine even on another serious
full-time basis like I think we should
have some sort of ground rules in and
understanding mutually so you tell me
what kind of stuff you not want to see
me doing electrons I don't mutually will
get there what are your ground rules
that's because a lot of girls think they
should be able to do whatever they want
now my problems are just uh respect if
that makes sense but in in a sense that
flies different ways for different
people you see what I'm saying but for
me I'm not yeah I don't I don't want
someone to send me a video like yo yo
ex-wan that isn't even mental do you see
what she just posted or do you see what
she's being photographed out and she was
in a club like getting alcohol thrown
over her and the man that was slapping
her ass I'm like that is a that works
for certain people some people get like
aroused by the situations and see all of
that and they're like yo that's my girl
that's sexy for me I'm like yo like
that's too much for me personally on my
little heart can't do it I'll be honest
you're saying you don't want other guys
slapping your girl's ass
yeah I prefer that this won't
happen
it's so controlling yeah like I'll
prefer it not to happen but if you feel
like yo I need that to happen that's
fine but you just call you can't be mine
and that's happening there's a guy out
there for you 100 but he's just not me
it's not you nah but I encourage you to
make you happy do what makes you happy
what do you say to the modern women that
will say
well centraling
go do what you want don't be controlled
100 hey I'm just not with you yeah just
not with me did you think most no but
you can do what you want with me but
just
like I'm not controlling I'm just I'll
just tell you now yo
I'm reasonable I'm not like yo like it
is the extremes for me it's not just
don't do these extremes and we should be
look you see what I'm saying what about
her going to a bar by herself or Club is
that okay
I knew what she wants to do it just
depends on how she carries herself it's
the same with me like if I go to work or
whatever I go to a bar it's all good but
if I'm it doesn't matter like whether I
go on my own in terms of my own house or
if I go back to your house if you're not
living together or whatever as long as
I'm back and I've checked in or whatever
I don't really expect there to be no
issues on it once vice versa see what
I'm saying as long as you're not hearing
seeing oh yeah this happened that
happened this happened as long as it's
not I don't me personally she's a
representation of you exactly yeah me
personally I don't understand why evil
one of each other's partner will want to
find themselves in a club without their
partner every weekend
personally I don't understand it if
that's what you want to do that's fine
at some point I'll tap out and be like
yo you in I'm done no and that's what we
talk about this all the time on my show
that's what I'm asking is um girls often
think it's crazy that a guy wouldn't
want her at a club
sure okay
oh it's um and to me that's just basic
like it was your mom at a club sure what
um yeah yeah love okay cool
um yeah
laughs
why what's funny no that's not the whole
thing I just didn't know what was that
one what I don't know what happened
nothing
all right let's move okay is there a
difference between UK engineering and
U.S engineering
no and yes
do you think we might also no one gets
like
it's just a ton like engineering
in both it's just perceived it for the
engineer in some aspects is what a
producer is and first of all I thought
it's all Technical and boring and none
of our fan base are here for it so we
can leave that for some reason but there
is some sort of difference but yeah are
you religious I wouldn't cause myself as
religious I do believe in God I do
believe we have a good relationship and
understanding I did try to work on
myself being better and uh yeah I don't
put it down to a religion
a statue a book do you ever produce
other genres yeah 100 I've done
everything
that heavy metal and rock country
yeah but not too really I mean yeah I
have
I want to I'd say do you know Lewis
Watson
I think he was country he's got the
guitar and all that stuff
you sure Lewis Watson maybe I think
that's mine yeah contrary oh okay it was
just a guitar and he's just singing he's
wow that's country music right
I'd have to hear it
but then it's like is it was Ed Sheeran
have a country no no it's like more pop
yeah I'll move you so he was a bit
different but when Ed Sheeran started at
the translations and that one well I'm
not transition whoever he was in public
with the singing his heart with the
guitar was that not like
what is country music then is it what
you have to be from a certain part for
it to I don't I don't know I just know
it when I hear it but at cheering it's
like
so y'all said Ed Sheeran doesn't do
country music at all no no he's Pop I
would say he's never done country music
that I know of no okay I I would say
he's pop they don't really have country
here that's why I was surprised
like they don't I haven't heard it if
they do I don't know what country music
is though never like Luke Combs Morgan
Wallen oh yeah definitely I'm not good
with the names in my industry I'm
definitely not going to that one yeah so
yeah who knows okay what what percent of
rappers would you say buy views
now I often rappers by views anymore no
no I feel like they pay for market and
Google ads and stuff but I don't I feel
like back in the day buying these was a
thing like one day the video will be on
5K views and within an hour it's on 105k
views no LAX has gone up no comments
have gone up just a mad Spike and then
within the next week it's on 106 KBS
like people used to do that but nowadays
they just spend money on marketing in
terms of ads and push out because that
is the new form of
essentially like you can look at it and
say that's the market now that's how
they're running the numbers and that's
the new growth mechanism
so I don't feel that that's the thing no
more people don't use bots in my opinion
but what Bots do that's when you just
get a mad spy car nowhere would it be
obvious who is doing it yeah yeah when
you're buying like bot views like they
come like Bam Bam Bam you can get them
staggered out but yeah I think people
buy Instagram followers and things or
followers and Twitter followers and the
verification it's like yeah not anymore
yeah now you can pay 11.99 for that
apparently
so yeah I don't know yeah so that you're
saying they do marketing now so they buy
do you think that's different than
buying views it seems like basically the
same thing
because I can call it that because
ultimately you are buying people's you
know what I'm saying because you're
marketing it if I stock a post on I paid
a thousand pounds to stick a post
outside your house I brought that space
for you to see it so I'm buying your
view if that makes sense as well as
whoever else lives in that area but
ultimately it's just Market it's what
everyone needs to do that means you can
take it away from YouTube and music and
Cinemas are buying views do you see what
I'm saying right because I kind of apply
that everywhere
what's your idea of a perfect date
depends on the vibe okay like I could
have a perfect date in this studio
okay
on a private jet
100 000 feet in the air or whatever so
you know what I'm saying like it depends
on the person they make the date the
perfect day not really the materialistic
stuff
see what I'm saying you can do nice
stuff little roses little jokes little
Netflix called it up on the sofa that
could be a perfect thing if it goes well
you see what I'm saying
at the Chicken Chopped it
it's definitely not perfectly that's
amazing
I looked perfect too the food looks good
yeah another food was actually lit
that's the best chicken nuggets and
chips I've got to beat them up brunch
together I say milk and I didn't get to
enjoying properly because the media was
you gotta keep your eye on the middle I
gotta keep my eye on her yeah like when
you're doing an interview you're gonna
keep an eye on that because she'll make
you look like you don't know what you're
talking about a little bit but she's so
funny she does such a good job of just
like putting banter in every
conversation
okay yeah that's nice but they're that
way hold on I was just trying to enjoy
this chicken let me hold on let me Focus
again what's the what's the maddest
interview question you've ever been
asked
I don't know like I just roll with the
punches really unless it's like personal
then certain things that I prefer not to
speak on like everyone deserves a
private support in their life even
public figures but
in in general
I don't know they all have their own
spin
have you ever heard of crazy
ex-girlfriend
[Laughter]
we've been there what do you mean what's
the craziest thing a girl's ever done
hacked on my social media
and emails everything
how you know how wait wait hold on hold
on
how did she do that I'm just kidding
I don't know man you'll never meet at
the Oscar in a sense of I won't tell you
so yeah okay but it's not X so yeah
wow she had so what'd she do just look
through everything
to know a lot
she could have done more unless you
don't know what she messaged girls or
what
she
could have done more but she done a lot
yeah it's mad
well thank you for coming in today it's
all good
um
next time I'll show you my rap skills
but I don't want to show off you know so
well for sure for sure we'll get it next
time we'll get one we'll get one you
have to come down and do it plugged in
yeah yeah
I actually I was on a freestyle show in
Miami and it was it was fun but I just
get so many you guys are so good wow I
might definitely have to get you that
you don't mind I can but I was like I
watched you guys do it and it was just
like oh I was like they're so good
I was like I'm not at that level oh can
we say the Miami's not gonna order but
the mommy wasn't good over there so you
could blend in no but you guys are just
crazy
guy you guys are like you guys are
phenomenal I mean you guys get millions
of views in every video
I try yeah I was just like oh my gosh
that's so intimidating
I don't know well I'm sure you're happy
anyway but yes for sure there's some
stuff that I definitely we're gonna what
we're gonna do Sonos